in this video i'm going to talk to you
about the single most important decision
that you can make in your business
career
and it has everything to do with
opportunity vehicles all right so for
the vast majority of people who watch
this it will go over your head but for a
very select few um it will be the thing
that creates the riches that that you'll
build your fortune off of
so if you don't know who i am my name is
alex ramose i own acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies that does about
85 million a year and i have nothing to
sell you and so uh the purpose of this
channel is that there's a lot of people
who are broke and i don't want you to be
one of them so mosey nation let's uh
lock in and rock and roll
so when i say opportunity vehicle what i
mean is what is the what is the
monetization structure that you're going
to monetize your skills and ultimately
the value that you provide in the
marketplace and so what i want to do is
kind of tell you a bit of a story to
illustrate this concept because it is
the single
most important concept that you will
probably ever have to grasp and this is
the element of strategy all right this
is people use the word strategy and they
throw it around because it sounds cool
but most people don't even know what it
is or how to really execute on it and so
the first story i want to tell you is
probably the the conversation that
changed my life the most
and so
this is probably five years ago i
joined a mastermind this is russell
brunson's mastermind
and at the time i had six locations uh
for my gyms and i had
seven eight nine and ten already planned
out i had picked the locations and i was
planning on doing build outs and
launching them so i could have 10
locations and my plan at the time was to
um be america's next gym so it was
united fitness was our brand i own the
trademark and it was an awesome you know
i was very excited about it as i was
kind of rattling off our stats and all
this stuff russell stopped me and was
like hey man i don't think you should do
that
and i was a little taken aback because
my thought was of you know joining this
mastermind was they're going to help me
accomplish my goals which was to become
america's gym
he said
you're so good at this he said you
you have a level 10 skill set and a
level two opportunity
and that really hit me it took me like a
ton of bricks because i was like here's
this guy that i looked up to who's who
was making more money than me i was kind
of in shock i didn't know what to really
say about it and so he paused and he
continued and he said
you shouldn't be
running these gyms he said you should be
showing people how you run these gyms
that's the difference he's like you
shouldn't be doing it you should be
showing other people how you're making
as much as you are with these facilities
and how you're opening them at full
capacity and how you've you know
reimagined the entire acquisition
process and how you're retaining clients
and how you're making more profit it was
a really hard decision for me because i
already had six locations i had
employees i had you know i had 30 plus
employees at the time and you know i had
tons of vendors that i had good
relationships with and it was a huge
pivot point in my life but ultimately i
decided to heed his advice because i
feel like if you don't listen to people
who you are asking for advice from now
this is with a grain of salt like you
should always make your own decisions
but you know one of the one of the
difficulties is seeing the unseen right
every billionaire right now can look at
my life and say like these are the
things that you cannot see and so it is
because i do not see that it's the
unknown unknowns that are the things
that are the risks in our life and so my
goal here with this channel is to
hopefully show you the things that i can
see to mitigate those those risks for
you all right so what i want to
illustrate here and this is what ended
up happening i'll tell you kind of like
the the the end result of that decision
at the end of this video um it was
pretty cool
but if we if we break this down right
i had some skills all right and there's
lots of them that i had um i had some i
had some
traits that were good for me right
and then i had some beliefs
now what i needed at this time in my
life is i needed an upgrade here i had
really strong skills and i had pretty
decent traits i would say i had the work
ethic i had the focus and things like
that and skills i knew how to scale
sales teams i already was running a six
person sales team at the time you know i
knew how to market
i knew how to provide fitness services
like those were all things right and so
if you think about this from a baseline
right i knew fitness that was my skill
set all right i knew how to help people
lose weight and i uh new business right
uh i knew marketing i knew sales i need
fulfillment for uh a a coaching style
business so these are let's just say
this is my base this is my base skill
set all right so the first level of this
opportunity would be me doing it
in person the next level of this
opportunity would be me doing this
remotely the next level of this
opportunity would be me going b2b and
licensing this model right to other
businesses
that already existed
the level above that biz op because now
my total adjustable market increases
right and so if you think about this and
i'll walk through each of these examples
in depth
but
each of these pretty much would add a
zero to my income and that is because
these opportunity vehicles
improve by an order of magnitude all
right it's a standard deviation and
literally when i say add zeros each time
was a 10x increase in my income and mind
you i haven't done this one
right so i'll i'll i'll explain that at
the end but this is now something that i
have the perspective from which to to at
least walk through this so you can
understand all right and so the first
thing is me doing this in person will
inherently limit my radius right so
every time i had to open a new location
i would be able to service a five to
seven mile radius right so that's over
here
that means that i could only serve these
tiny little amount of people
when i was doing this to go up in
magnitude right as soon as you can start
servicing remotely and so my income went
from
five figures
per month here to six figures per month
here to seven figures per month here and
i would imagine that if i had made this
next jump it would probably jump to
eight figures per month over here and so
understanding this is going to be the
key to ultimately how much money you
make in your life the thing is is that
in order to progress through these
opportunity vehicles levels
the foundation upon which you build will
be based on the nuance and the depth of
your skill which comes from experience
from doing the thing before so another
way to think about this is a pyramid
right and the thing is is that the wider
the base of this pyramid
the taller
the peak will ultimately become right
and so if i have a tiny pyramid my
absolute peak of this thing is going to
be tiny and if i have a much bigger
pyramid because i have a much bigger
base
i'm going to have a much much bigger
overall income this is when i had i was
making ten thousand a month this got me
to a hundred thousand dollars a month
one million dollars plus per month and i
think that what will happen next because
i think i understand how to do this now
the next thing that i do will probably
get me past 10 million dollars per month
which you guys are sort of seeing
already said acquisition.com is on pace
to do that probably end of next year the
idea here was
local remote
and then this transition
here was the b2b transition and then
this is the tam transition
so with each of these increases or
opportunity vehicle changes
we're able to make more money right it's
because
here from local to remote we serve more
customers
from remote to b2b
we ultimately
transform the value that we're able to
provide
from helping lots of people lose weight
to helping a handful of people that make
a lot more money and then from here
we went from b2b
from a very small amount of people to a
very large amount of people all right
and so if i were to um continue to
want to
grow
gym launch for example then what i would
do
would be to probably franchise that and
the reason that franchising would work
there is it transforms that business
from a professional services business
which is what it is which takes existing
business owners um within that vehicle
and improving their bottom line and top
line to taking people who are not in the
game at all and so there are four more
people who would like to make money
through a gym then there are gym owners
and so by extension this would be a
better opportunity vehicle all right and
so i'll probably end up coming with a
framework for this but when russell told
me you're a level
two opportunity he meant this
he meant it's very difficult for you to
scale this nationally now not to say
that you can't it's just that this is
the operation that i will share with you
as well is that i have dealt with a
tremendous amount of business owners you
know through our professional services
businesses when i can see somebody who
has let's say 10 locations of brick and
mortar when you have 10 locations your
skill set
is that of somebody who could move up in
the opportunity vehicle schema all right
and so what happens is you get stuck in
these inferior opportunity vehicles
where the level of effort the level of
leverage you have is significantly less
and so i'll tell you this quote from
warren buffett that really like gives me
the shivers he tells the story of his
one of his closest friends from colombia
so he went to columbia business school
and he said there was this fellow that
was very bright very hard-working very
ethical very good friends with warren
and they both ended up doing their own
thing warren went to make his first
partnership in investments and
this other guy went into the steel
business all right and he said over the
rest of his career he said the other
fellow made good income but never really
made anything spectacular and he said it
taught him this single lesson
it is more important
what boat you are in rather than how
hard you row
and so this is why when we talk about
picking markets right picking markets is
one of the most important decisions that
you make because you feel you see who
you are going after if you look at this
process that i'm looking at here this is
a market selection process so another
word for mark for opportunity vehicles
what is the market selection we're going
after now it is important to niche down
first
you start small
and then you expand up as your skill set
increases
you find out how to consistently deliver
high value to a particular marketplace
and then you expand to another vertical
right and then you expand to another
vertical which can either be wider or
adjacent either of those things and so
when i when i thought about that it's
all about
the boat that you are in rather than how
hard you row that is why for example a a
bad business owner or a mediocre
business owner might have entered
cannabis five years ago and killed it a
bad business owner might have entered
crypto space five years ago and now kill
it and there are probably far more
skilled
entrepreneurs in other opportunity
vehicles who made less money and it was
not because of how hard they rode
but
what boat they were in and so the single
greatest decision that you can look at
is going to be your opportunity vehicle
and so i'm saying this live with you
because i'm thinking through this out
loud but it would probably be a function
of two things market times deliverable
all right and so the market is going to
be all the things that i just went over
and for those who don't know this
channel it's you want to find somebody
who's really easy to find you want a
growing marketplace you want them to
have money and you want them to be in
pain all right so that you have
something that you can solve for them
that's a really sad smiley face all
right in terms of delivery the two
highest forms of this all right in terms
of opportunity vehicles and this is
borrowed from naval ravicon right
is that you've got
code
capital cooperation
which is labor right
and then you've got content or media and
so the higher up you go on this thing
the more leverage you will have in your
deliverable
and so for example if you have a super
high leverage deliverable in a very good
four out of four marketplace you will
probably make you will have a level
10 opportunity
if you are in a hard-to-find market that
is shrinking or not growing that fast
that has low purchasing power and people
that are not that much pain and you're
doing something that is low
on this leverage scale you will have a
level
one opportunity and so what i'll do is
i'll finish the story that i started at
the beginning of this which is what
happened
once i made this switch so what happened
for me
is i i fire sold the gyms that i had the
six gyms that i had over the next 90
days or so
and then i started flying out and
launching other people's gyms for them
so i would fill gyms to capacity in 30
days that was the promise i said i'll
fill you gym in 30 days guaranteed and
they never needed to pay me and i
operated 100 on performance so it was a
very easy offer to sell
that scaled up to about 350 000
per month and from there
i went up this vehicle so that was when
i was using
cooperation for my employees
and then i switched to here
which was content so we switched to a
licensing model
and then from there we went to 4.4
million per month
by making that switch
and the key thing that i want to draw
your attention to
to go back to the very beginning of the
story
is that
my skills
more or less remained unchanged
and that's
the moral of this story is that my
skills remained more or less unchanged i
had this skill set but when i
maximized
the opportunity vehicle
that i was pursuing
which was a function of
market
times the leverage of my deliverable i
was able to make significantly more
money and so this is the single greatest
decision that you will have to make with
the portfolio companies that we take on
what i'm often looking at is how can we
increase the opportunity vehicle that we
are working with the base skill set of
the entrepreneur and so a lot of times
it's a very short conversation that can
dramatically change the trajectory of
that individual's life and ultimately
their net worth and the fortune that
they build
simply based on on structuring the
business in a different way and figuring
out a better way to package those skills
into a different or superior marketplace
and so that is ultimately uh i would say
the cornerstone of this big word that
people throw around all the time the
strategy
is knowing who you're going after and
more specifically
who you are not going after so that you
can ultimately make the most money so
anyways um i hope you found value in
this uh if you did hit the subscribe
button if you did not i love you either
way keeping awesome osu nation uh like i
said my name is alex for moses moon
acquisition.com i have absolutely
nothing to sell you keep being awesome
i'll see you guys next video bye